so with agents of shield coming back
again today and with us learning about
the fact that Daisy Johnson is quake
that she isn't inhuman I figured it'd be
a good idea to make a video explaining
who Daisy Johnson is and Marvel Comics
what her role is and so what we're going
to be doing in this video is we're going
to kind of be juxtaposing the two
characters jay-z Daisy Johnson from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe from agents of
shield and Daisy Johnson from the comic
books
so Daisy Johnson first appears in the
five issue limited series secret war now
this is not to be confused with the 1984
story of Secret Wars this is a totally
separate beast and in fact for a lot of
Marvel Comics fans the way that we
differentiate is by simply referring to
this story as fury secret war but this
was basically a five-part limited series
that was a lead-in to both Civil War and
Secret Invasion this is what Marvel used
to set the stage for two different
things the first thing was to basically
remove Nick Fury as the director of
shield and to put Maria hill in his
place this is the reason why Maria Hill
is the director of shield with regards
to the Civil War conflict the other
thing was that this was a lead-up to the
Secret Invasion storyline whereby the
scrolls are replacing both superhero
super villains and normal humans on the
planet Earth so they could effectively
take over the planet this is the story
that gave us the reason why Nick Fury is
underground during the entire Civil War
and Secret Invasion conflict and why it
is that he's the first point of contact
that is to say chronologically the first
person that realized that the scrolls
are taking over the planet Earth now
Daisy Johnson doesn't actually appear
until issue number two but in order to
make this make sense I kind of had to
give you guys a little bit of an
explanation with regards to the civil to
the Secret Wars story this was basically
a story where by Nick Fury had learned
that the newly I guess a newly placed
prime minister Lucia von Barros who was
basically the Prime Minister of Latveria
after dr. doom had been removed was
basically funding terrorism in the
United States by giving small level
super villains the kind of technology
they needed in order to implement their
plans and this was done by using a
go-between in the form of a person
called the tinkerer the kind of person
that would basically create these
devices but she was also kind of playing
this on two fronts not only was she
funding terrorism but she was basically
repairing the mends repairing the rift
between Liberia and the United States
and so as far as the government was
concerned she was carrying out the kind
of role that she should be carrying out
and making things better when in reality
she was tricking everybody the whole
time now Nick Fury eventually learns
what it is that Lucia Vaughn bardos is
doing and so what he does is he
assembles a team composed of Natasha
Romanoff Captain America spider-man
Wolverine along with Daisy Johnson and
daredevil as a way to basically
infiltrate the the country of Latveria
and to kill off lucia von bardos
entirely but again during this entire
conflict Daisy Johnson doesn't actually
appear until issue number two and when
she shows up an issue number two one she
looks almost exactly like Angelina Jolie
which is the way that she was designed
by Brian Michael Bendis but too no one
knows her name and in fact she won't
tell people what her name is she simply
says if they're supposed to know what
her name is
then they would know already indicating
to us that her and Nick Fury have a
relationship not necessarily romantic
but more like a I guess like a mentor
and a protege kind of relationship that
goes beyond anything that any of the
shield agents or even the superheroes
are aware of and so what happens is that
over the course of this conflict we
learn a little bit more about Daisy
Jocelyn we learn a little bit here and
there but not a whole lot it's not
actually until issue number five that we
learned quite a bit about her character
or at least as much as Brian Michael
Bendis gives us and what we learn is
that once Nick Fury has been removed as
the director of shield and Maria Hill
has stepped into his role that she
begins interrogating Daisy Johnson and
we learn her name is Daisy Johnson
against something we didn't know up
until this point we also learned she has
the ability to to enact seismic activity
to basically make earthquakes but she
can do this in a very very fine way that
is to say she has almost total control
over her abilities and in fact we'll see
her implement the fine-tuning of these
abilities once we actually get into the
story of her and the the Avengers in the
x-men dealing with Magneto following the
House of M but with her character one of
the other things that Maria Hill
basically informs us of is that no one
knows who she is there's not a single
person that understands why she's there
or what she's capable of all they know
is that she's a level-10 SHIELD agent
meaning that she's the only other person
besides that Nick Fury or Natasha
Romanoff that has that high of a level
of clearance but no one understands why
and Brian Michael Bendis doesn't really
give us a direct answer in the story
it's not actually until we get into the
information post event that is to say
the files of Nick Fury as it's referred
to and a lot of these different stories
that we actually learned that she was
basically a student of Nick
that for some reason or another she had
basically gained powers as a result of
being the daughter of mr. Hyde and the
comics and that as a result she was
taken in by Nick Fury and taught how to
use her abilities and this is it this is
all we get we don't get anything other
than that Brian Michael Bendis does not
in any real way expand on the history of
her character and neither does Marvel
and the reason why is I would go as far
as to say is because she wasn't designed
to be a mainstay character she wasn't
designed to be a character on par with
Captain America or spider-man Attorney
of those guys and in fact Marvel goes as
far as to say this when we pick up
during the events after the house of m1
with the house of M story if you guys
recall our discussion on that that is
conclusion ninety-eight percent of the
mutant population lost their powers and
so the question was where do all these
powers go what happened to the mole and
Marvel answers this question by creating
something called a collective which is
an amalgamation of all the powers that
were gone and so once a collective takes
on various house it actually ends up
bonding itself with magneto in Genosha
and when it does magneto has I guess
becomes drunk with power has hitherto
unchecked abilities and he's confronted
by the x-men and The Avengers alongside
with shield agents which include quake
and so what what Daisy Johnson does here
is she uses her abilities to basically
cause a murmur inside the body of a
Magneto effectively knocking him
unconscious
using her earthquake abilities basically
to create an earthquake inside the body
of Magneto now this is the first time
that we actually see her use the moniker
quake and the way this happens is that
once the event is over and she had been
fighting alongside the Avengers she
speaks with Captain America believing
that this was really more of a test the
Avengers were wanting to inductor induct
her into their ranks but Captain America
says no but what she says is that she
would rather use the codename quake if
she's going to be part of the Avengers
now following this she really just kind
of falls to the background she really
kind of Falls to appearing periodically
throughout various stories dark rain
things like that during Secret Invasion
again a story where the scrolls were
replacing humans super villains and
super uh super heroes with scroll
replacements she was a person who was a
contact for Nick Fury she was giving
Nick Fury the information he needed
while he was underground she was one of
the only people or the only person who
actually knew where Nick Fury
or what he was doing but even then he
only really communicated by hologram but
in addition to this she's also a
character that was part of age of Ultron
and during age of Ultron she was one of
the few superheroes who had survived and
she had also fought along alongside Nick
Fury when they would Linnea travel into
the future and of course was one of the
people who was killed here
but again the character is she appears
in the comics is vastly different than
the character that we see in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and the reason for
this is because Marvel's basically
because I guess capitalizing on the lack
of history that Brian Michael Bendis
gave us and the muffled cinematic
universe we know that by going through
the episodes of agents of shield that we
can trace back the lineage the history
of Daisy Johnson here in saying that one
she is of course as in the comics the
daughter of mr. Hyde but we didn't know
who her mother was and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they're saying her
mother is this unidentified woman from
China who had longevity who was most
likely in and human although model I
guess the ages of she'll doesn't really
point to that and say that it's
absolutely true we know that somewhere
along the line during all of this that
Daisy Johnson was left as an orphan she
was taken to an orphanage eventually she
had left and she had all t'me met up
with shield where of course we know that
that really picks up with the ADIS of
shield TV series we know that for the
most part this character that's being
presented to us in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is far more interesting and is
more in depth than her comic book
counterpart simply because of the fact
that the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Marvel has an opportunity to basically
rewrite her character and to make her
more riveting to take what little
information was given to us in the
comics to discard it because in truth it
doesn't really matter all that much and
then to basically just give us something
brand-new
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys on it
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly